[Music]  since this is Comic Con there is no  better place in the world than to do one  thing have an epic lightsaber battle I  think this is the place to do it  how would you folks like to see me and  Andy have an epic  [Applause]  come on Annie come on Eddie come on  Annie what are you doing come on wait a  minute Abby I've got no verb Conan no  pep maybe what's wrong you got you look  like you look terrible out here you're  sluggish don't have any energy all right  I know what's gonna help you out old pal  and that's one thing right here that's  right a Snickers bar  they're good in situations like this  yeah ah no one running  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  lightsaber battle  brought to you by seekers  you